THE ROLL SENATORS BATES MINING
ROTH.
ROTH HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILL
CURE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU AND I'M AWARE THAT.
I TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
EITHER ON THEIR WAY ONE IS STILL
IN A DIFFERENT COMMITTEE SO --
THEY WILL JOIN US AS SOON AS
THEY ARE ABLE BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED --
I AM HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION%
WHICH WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN. FOR OTHERS TO JOIN ON OF
FOR ITEMS TO REFERRAL OF BILLS.
THREE AND FOUR SELECT COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS.
OUR FIVE SUBCOMMITTEE
RATIFICATION.
OUR ITEM SIX AND SEVEN WHICH ARE
FLOOR EIGHT KNOWLEDGE MEN'S --
AS A MOTION OF SOMEONE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE A MOTION --
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES
MONNING ROTH ROTH AYE WILK HI
WILK AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
AND NOT PICK THIS UP AGAIN LATER.
OUT WITH THAT LET ME GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED AND INVITE OUR
APPOINTEE.
MR WADE CROW FIT --
FOOT SORRY BROKE WOULD CIRCLE.
AND I MISTER CRAWFORD IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HERE WITH YOU AND GO
AHEAD AND GO INTO YOUR COMMENTS
AND STATEMENT.
THEY WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE WELCOME THANKS SO MUCH.
BOTTOM PRO TEM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY.
I AND FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
MY CONFIRMATION.
I AM TRULY HONORED TO BE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
SERVICE NOW TO RESOURCES
SECRETARY AND REALLY EXCITED TO
SHARE WITH YOU MY APPROACH TO
THE WORK --
AS A PRO TEM INVITED ME I'D SET
UP A TIME AND BYE TO ME TOO I
WANTED TO INTRODUCE MY FAMILY
FIRST -- MY
WIFE LISA.
IN A WAVE ON MY DAUGHTER CALLA
WHO IS HIDDEN BEHIND THAT THE
FIRST ROW HARDWARE COLORING.
SHE MAY OR MAY NOT GET VERY
BORED WITH HER PAPA --
TALKING --
AND MY MOM --
DALE WHO'S VISITING FROM
MICHIGAN HER FIRST TIME IN
SACRAMENTO AND ARE GOOD FAMILY
FRIEND I. T. --
LEVITT MALL TIA WAS LAST IN
ADVOCATING AND OVER LUNCH DONT
DOWNSTAIRS SHE DID ANNOUNCE THAT
SHE'S GOING TO BE A GOVERNOR ONE
DAY SO.
CIRCA TWENTY FORTY TWO OR TWENTY
FORTY SIX PROBABLY GIVEN HER AGE.
I'M.
AND BEFORE I BEFORE I SHARE WITH
YOU MY VISION AND MY APPROACH I
I JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WOMEN AND MEN AT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
I WERE BIG AGENCY --
TWENTY SIX BOARDS DEPARTMENTS IN
COMMISSIONS NINETEEN THOUSAND
STAFF STRONG.
AND THE PROGRESS THAT I'M
EXCITED TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY
IS REALLY THE PRODUCT OF THEIR
WORK -- OVER
YEARS AND SOMETIMES DECADES.
AND IT'S BEEN HIGHLIGHTED MY
FIRST COUPLE MONTHS ON THE JOB
TO ACTUALLY MEET A LOT OF STAFF --
THAT I WOULDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET AND ELEVATOR
AROUND THE BUILDING AND LEARN OF
THEIR WORK AND THEIR CAREERS I
ACTUALLY I IN THERE AND THE
PASSION SO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR WORK SOMETIMES
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THE WORK THAT --
THAT WE'RE DOING TOGETHER AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE HOUSE OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THE HARD
WORK ON THE FRONT LINES --
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT MOMENT. FOR
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
ON THE ONE HAND WE HAVE A RANGE
OF CHALLENGES --
THREATS TO NATURAL RESOURCES ARE
GROWING AS YOU KNOW CLIMATE
CHANGE ISWORSENING DROUGHT
FLOODS WILDFIRES.
SEA LEVEL RISE IN COASTAL
EROSION THREATEN OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR COASTLINE.
ARE RISING TEMPERATURES IN THE
SO CALLED HEAT ISLAND COMPLEX
ARE GONNA THREATEN PUBLIC HEALTH
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ARE IN YEARS AND DECADES TO COME.
AT THE SAME TIME OUR POPULATION
IS GROWING YOU KNOW UPWARDS OF
FIFTY MILLION PEOPLE OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DECADES.
OUR ECONOMY IS EXPANDING ALREADY
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
THOSE ARE OF COURSE VERY GOOD
THINGS BUT THEY DO PLACE DEMANDS
ON OUR NATURAL RESOURCES I
INCLUDING WATER AND LAND.
I'M AND THEN AND THEN THIRDLY AS
THESE CHALLENGES HAVE EVOLVED
OVER RECENT DECADES OF FUNDING
HAS NOT NECESSARILY KEEP KEPT
PLATE PACE.
I PARTICULARLY GIVEN FEDERAL
DIVESTMENT IN AREAS LIKE A WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO WHILE WE WERE WE HAVE THOSE
CHALLENGES TO CONTEND WITH I
THINK E'RE REALLY WELL
POSITIONED TO TACKLE THEM HEAD
ON OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
HAVE A LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
WHO HAVE PRIORITIZED AND
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE NATURAL
RESOURCES.
THINK ABOUT --
WILDFIRE AND FOREST MANAGEMENT
PRIORITY RIGHT NOW AND SENATE
BILL NINE A ONE THAT'S REALLY
PROVIDING A FRAMEWORK FOR THAT.
AS AN EXAMPLE.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE ALLOCATED
OVER TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
LAST DECADE FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES.
COURSE PROPOSITION ONE THE WATER
BOND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN MOST
RECENTLY PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
I IN JUNE.
AND THEN MAYBE MOST PROBABLY
CALIFORNIANS FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
WORKING TO DO WHAT NATURAL
RESOURCES.
AND THAT IS PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT I IN WAYS THAT
ACTUALLY ALLOW US TO UTILIZE OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR QUALITY OF LIFE
AND IN OUR ECONOMY.
SO WHAT WE HAVE CHALLENGES I
THINK WE'RE REALLY WELL
POSITIONED. TO ADDRESS HOSE
CHALLENGES.
THEY'LL BE TO PRIORITIES --
THAT WILL GUIDE OR SHAPE A LOT
OF MY WORK I IT HOPEFULLY IN IN
COMING MONTHS AND YEARS.
I'M ONE IS --
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
NATURAL SYSTEMS BECOME MORE
RESILIENT TO THESE CHALLENGES.
I'M SO NATURAL RESOURCES ON THE
A REAL TRINITY OF THREATS THE
FLOODS THE DROUGHTS THE WILD
FIRES.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO REDOUBLE
OUR EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PROTECT PEOPLE THE COMMUNITIES
ARE FROM.
THOSE IMPACTS ON THOSE THREATS
IN OUR NATURAL SYSTEMS THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE THAT DEPEND ON THEM --
WE THINK ABOUT THE INTENSE FOCUS
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE ON PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRE.
I IN THE WAKE OF THE CAMPFIRE IN
THE TRAGEDY IN PARADISE.
THAT'S ONE CURRENT COMPELLING
EXAMPLE OF THE RESILIENCE THE
TYPE OF WORK WE NEED TO DO
BUILDING RESILIENCE.
THE SECOND BROAD PRIORITY IS TO
BETTER CONNECTOR STRENGTH IN THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN PEOPLE AND
NATURE PEOPLE AND NATURAL PLACES.
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO FOLLOW THE
LEGISLATURE'S LEAD ON HELPING TO
IMPLEMENT.
A VISION TO EXPAND PARK ACCESS
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY
THOSE CALIFORNIANS THAT LIVING
COMMUNITIES NOW THAT HAVEN'T --
TRADITIONALLY BEEN ABLE TO ENJOY
PARKS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THOSE PARTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SO AS WE BEGIN THIS WORK --
AND AS I HOPE TO BEGIN THIS WORK
I MEAN I'LL I'LL APPLY AT LEAST
FOUR BROAD PRINCIPLES.
NOT. TO TO THESE PRIORITIES.
NUMBER ONE IS TO BE GUIDED BY
SCIENCE --
WE ARE LUCKY TO BE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THE RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
IN THE ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
THAT WE HAVE.
NOW TO RESOURCE MANAGEMENT IS
COMPLICATED AND SO AND
EVERYTHING FROM WATER TO FISH
AND WILDLIFE TO FORESTRY WE NEED
TO WE NEED TO BE GUIDED BY YOU
KNOW OBJECTIVE SCIENCE AND
MONITORING [inaudible]
SECOND PRINCIPLE.
THAT I REALLY WANT TO BRING TO
THE WORK IS TO BREAK DOWN SILOS
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
AND MY EXPERIENCE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
OFTENTIMES IN SUCH LARGE
ORGANIZATIONS EITHER CAN BE
REALLY A DISCONNECT.
AMONG THE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES AND SO WHILE WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOWARD THE SAME MAN
OFTENTIMES THERE'S DUPLICATION
OR CONFLICT I WHEN WE'RE WHEN
WE'RE NOT WORKING TO BE
INTEGRATED.
THIRD PRINCIPLE IS TO PRIORITIZE
COLLABORATION WITH FOLKS OUTSIDE
OF GOVERNMENT.
SO TO GET OUT OF THAT BUBBLE
THAT IS SACRAMENTO AND ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND --
THE IMPACTS OF OUR WORK I'M
GROUPS LIKE OF FARMERS AND
FORESTERS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION GROUPS.
HI COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
SO WE NEED TO GET OUT THERE
ACTUALLY IN PROACTIVE EMPHASIS
ON COMMUNITIES --
THAT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
PAST CONVERSATIONS.
SO THAT REALLY SPEAKS TO THE THE
ELEVATION OF EQUITY I
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
AND IN THE FOURTH PRINCIPLE I
THINK WHICH IS IMPORTANT THIS
ROLE IS TO BUILD A REALLY STRONG
TEAM.
BUILDING ON THE TALENTED WOMEN
AND MEN WE HAVE A THE AGENCY
ALREADY MY GOAL IS TO BUILD A
DIVERSE TEAM --
WITH A SET OF LEADERS --
THAT KNOW THEIR WORK --
AND THAT WANT TO MAKE CHANGE AND
EMPOWER THEM TO EAD.
I THINK THEY NEED TO DO REALLY.
FOR THINGS FIRST IS REALLY SICK
TO UNDERSTAND ALL VIEW POINTS I
AM THE ISSUES THAT WE FACE.
ARE SECONDLY IS TO ROLL UP
SLEEVES AND ACTUALLY DIRECTLY
ENGAGE IN PROBLEM SOLVING --
AND TO AVOID.
AN APPROACH WEBER JUST HAVE US
AGAIN IN THE RESOURCES AGENCY
REACTIVE BUT MUCH MORE PROACTIVE.
NOW COMMUNICATE CAN
CONSTRUCTIVELY INDIRECTLY.
I AND THEN LASTLY MAKE DECISIONS
IN A CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT AND
DECISIVE WAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO GET
DONE AND MY GOAL FOR OUR TEAM TO
COMMUNICATE WITH YOU ON THE
LEGISLATURE OTHER AGENCIES
STAKEHOLDERS.
GATHER INFORMATION WE NEED TO
AND THEN REALLY MAKE DECISIONS
AND MAKE PROGRESS IMPLEMENTING
POLICIES MADE IN THIS BUILDING
AND BY THE GOVERNOR.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE WORK
AND AM EXCITED ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME
START WITH THE GOOD SENATOR TO
MY RIGHT HERE SENATOR ROTH.
pCRAWFORD CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU HAVE A VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE --
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND AND SEEMS
TO ME FROM REVIEWING YOUR
CREDENTIALS AT YOUR WORK
EXPERIENCES EXTREMELY
SIGNIFICANT AND RELEVANT TO THE
TEST THAT --
YOU'VE BEEN --
DESIGNATED TO PERFORM SO
CONGRATULATIONS AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO OF A MAKING THE
MOTION AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
TO CONFIRM YOUR APPOINTMENT.
WITH FOR THIS IS NOT YOUR FIRST
RODEO WITH RESPECT TO HAVING TO
DEAL WITH NATURAL DISASTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
THAT WITH THE PER [inaudible]
ADMINISTRATION.
SO AND BASED ON THAT EXPERIENCE
[inaudible]
VERY VERY.
INTENSE EXPERIENCE I'M SURE.
WHAT OURS OURS SPECIFIC OPTIONS
WITH RESPECT?
TO ATTEMPTING TO REDUCE THE
SCOPE OF THESE FOREST RELATED
DISASTERS THE CERTAINLY HAVE
BEEN OUR IMMEDIATE PAST AND LOOK
TO BE OUR FUTURE.
PERHAPS VERY VERY FAR DISTANT
FUTURE.
YEAH SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE TO PURSUE AN ALL OF THE
ABOVE APPROACH AND I'LL TALK
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY FACING A
DOUBLE WHAMMY WHEN IT COMES --
TO WILDFIRE THREATS.
ON THE ONE HAND WE HAVE DRYER
FORESTS WE HAVE AN EPIDEMIC OF
TREE MORTALITY --
WE HAVE HEIGHTENED RISKS OF
THESE MEGA FIRES I LIKE WE SEEN.
AND AT THE SAME TIME OUR
DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE WORKED TO
SUPPRESS FIRES TO PROTECT LIVES
OVER A CENTURY.
I AND SO WE HAVE FOREST'S THAT
ARE --
REALLY IN --
AND THE FIRES WITH EXPERIENCE OF
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AS YOU
KNOW TWENTY EIGHTEEN EASILY THE
MOST DEVASTATING.
WILDFIRE YEAR IN TERMS OF LOSS
OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
SO PART OF THE ANSWER IS
ACTUALLY ACTIVE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR FORESTS --
BOTH AROUND COMMUNITIES AND MORE
BROADLY AT THE LANDSCAPE LEVEL.
GOVERNOR NEW SOME ON HIS FIRST
FULL DAY IN OFFICE ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTING CAL
FIRE TO IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO RIGHT
NOW. TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES --
SO WE DON'T HAVE THE TRAGEDY OF
WE MINIMIZE THE RISK OF THE
TRAGEDY OF PARADISE HAPPENING
THIS FIRE SEASON.
ARE IN SO CAL FIRE ISSUED --
A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS AND I'M
SPENDING A LOT OF MY TIME RIGHT
NOW WORKING TO GET THIRTY FIVE
EMERGENCY PROJECTS ON THE GROUND
AROUND COMMUNITIES TO PROTECT
TWO HUNDRED ON A BOOK
COMMUNITIES.
SO THERE'S WORK IN THE FORCE
THAT WE NEED TO DO.
BUT THERE'S ALSO WORK IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE NEED TO DO --
AS I HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
SOME OF YOU ABOUT --
THE NATURE OF SOME OF THESE
FIRES IS --
HEAVILY WIND DRIVEN EVENTS SO IN
SOME FLAMING EMBERS --
FLOATING HEAD OF THE FIRE LINE
TWO THREE MILES --
AND SO WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE
HOME HARDENING I THAT IS THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO WITH OUR EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK NEW HOUSING STOCK
TO PROTECT THOSE --
HOMES ARE FROM IGNITING.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO REPAIR
COMMUNITIES --
OBVIOUSLY --
THERE ARE YOU KNOW ALMOST A
HUNDRED PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES
IN PARADISE BUT WHAT'S LAST
KNOWN IN PARADISE IS THAT WAS A
COMMUNITY THAT HAD REALLY.
THRILLED QUITE EXTENSIVELY ON
EVACUATIONS.
AND PART OF THE REASON WHY THERE
WEREN'T MANY MORE DEATHS IS THAT
ACTUALLY THAT COMMUNITY
EVACUATED VERY QUICKLY.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE
THAT ARE NOT AS WELL PREPARED --
SO WE HAVE TO WORKERS YOU KNOW
CAL FIRE IS PART OF THE SOLUTION
BUT WE HAVE TO WORK ACROSS
AGENCIES --
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO LEADING
THAT EFFORT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING YOU DO
THAT CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM.
THE VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
WE HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT MY
CONCERN ABOUT AG NOT GETTING
ENOUGH WATER BECAUSE THEY TAKE A
LOT OF WATER AND IT'S ONLY ABOUT
2% OF GDP.
AND YOU'RE SURE TO ME THAT THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE GOOD ON THAT.
I'M JUST CURIOUS BECAUSE I HEARD
HIM THIS MORNING FOR THE FIRST
TIME I MIGHT BE MISSING PREP
PRONOUNCING HIS NAME I I WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT HE'S
A HE'S A PROFESSOR UC DAVIS DR
FRANK.
MEANT LOTION --
NOTHING REALLY WITHIN SO HE SELL
BE HE IS ALL ABOUT SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE AND ANDHOW WE CAN
REDUCE OUR OUR OUR OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT THROUGH THAT I LOVE TO
PUT YOU GUYS TOGETHER.
I IT WAS INCREDIBLY FASTENING
HIS HIS TWITTER HANDLE.
IS A G. H. G. GURU.
AND SO I SURF ALL HIM TODAY SO I
I RECOMMEND THAT SO.
HE DOES GREAT SO I WANT SO MUCH
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE OBVIOUSLY
AND I BET YOU KNOW I'M SOMEBODY
THAT BELIEVES THERE'S CLIMATECHANGE I MEAN I THINK THERE'S
ENOUGH DATA THERE --
BEEN WITH FARMERS IN NAPA OVER
CHANGED OUT THERE OF RYE OTHER
VARIETALS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
GROW CHARDONNAY ANYMORE.
I'VE BEEN IN CHILE WHERE THE
ARTISANAL FISHERMEN HAD TO
CHANGE WHAT KIND OF FISH THEY
ARE CATCHING AND I'VE BEEN DOWN
THE GPL --
YOU KNOW TRACKING JASON NINE
WHICH TAX OF SEA LEVEL RISE.
I THINK HERE WE DO ANY IN HOW WE
DRESS IT IS TOO MUCH ON THE
REGULATORY AND TAXATION SIDE.
AND NOT ENOUGH ON ON THE INSIDE
ANY.
AREAS WE SEE WHERE WE COULD BE
PROVIDING AND INCENTIVES TO TO
REDUCE GLOBAL EMISSIONS YEAH
I'LL ANSWER THAT QUESTION
ACTUALLY BRIDGE YOUR FOR YOUR
FIRST COMMON IF I COULD.
SO.
YOU KNOW FROM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND CERTAINLY TAKING
THE LEAD FROM THE GOVERNOR WE
NEED A BALANCE WATER POLICY AND
ABOUT --
WATER POLICY THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF CITIESAND TOWNS.
ARE KANA ME AGRICULTURE IN THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
AND SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
ACTUALLY HELP CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE I CONTINUE TO THRIVE.
I'M SOME FOLKS BROUGHT A NUMBER
THAT SAYS AGRICULTURE IS ONLY 2%
OF GDP WHY THEY USE AS MUCH
WATER WHEN I ANSWER IS.
YOU KNOW GROWING FOOD AND FIBER.
TAKES A LOT OF WATER I AND WE
OBVIOUSLY ALL NEED THAT --
A LARGE REGION OF OUR ECONOMY
WITH FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
CENTRAL VALLEY DEPENDS ON THAT
AS THEIR LIFEBLOOD AND OF COURSE
THE LIFEBLOOD OF AGRICULTURE IS
WATER -- SO
WHILE WE MODERNIZE OUR OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE WATER MANAGEMENT
WE HAVE TO WORK WITH AGRICULTURE
SO IT CAN IT HAS A WATER CAN
CONTINUE TO THRIVE.
YOUR POINT ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND WHERE YOU CAN ACTUALLY FIND
INCENTIVES AGRICULTURE ISA IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT SECTOR THAT'S A
PARTNER I'M ACTUALLY REDUCING
EMISSION REDUCTION AND MUTE A
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND CAPTURING.
OUR CARBON --
WE CAN CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
FARMING PRACTICES THAT ACTUALLY
GENERATE ANCILLARY REVENUE
STREAMS FOR FARMERS --
IN WAYS THAT ACTUALLY SEQUESTER
CARBON AND PROVIDE A HABITAT
BENEFITS --
DISKETTES TALKED ABOUT AS
ECOSYSTEM BUDDY A STEWARD OR
RANCHER A FARMER AND THERE ARE A
STEWARD OF THE LAND YES THERE
RAISING FOOD THEY MIGHT BE
RAISING LIVESTOCK OR CROPS.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO --
MAKING MONEY I CONTRIBUTING TO
OTHER PUBLIC VALUES INCLUDING
OUR CLIMATE EFFORTS IN PROVIDING
HABITAT FOR EXAMPLE A THREATENED.
SPECIES SO I'M REALLY EXCITED ON
IT WITHIN THE AGENCY MORE NOT
FUNDAMENTALLY REGULATORY AGENCY
TO REALLY EXPLORE WHERE THERE
CAN BE WIN WIN VOLUNTARY
INCENTIVES.
MADAM MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AS QUESTIONS
LOOKING FORWARD TO VOTING FOR
YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY CONGRATS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN MISTER
CRAWFORD CONGRATULATIONS AND WE
HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION NOW.
WHEN YOU CAME OUT AND VISITED US
FIGHTING HIM [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
MORE THAN PERSONALLY OR
PERSONALLY OF THAT I THINK OF
THAT TIME I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT TWO ISSUES
FLUBS CERTAINLY FOLLOWING UP ON
MY COLLEAGUES.
A SENATOR WILK CONCERNED ABOUT
CHILD CLIMATE CHANGE IN IN MY
COMMUNITY AT SEA RISE.
AND OTHER AREAS MANY THAT'S BEEN
APPROPRIATED THROUGH A
CONSERVANCY AND BASICALLY GONE
MORE NORTH SIDE TO SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'M HOPING THAT YOU'LL TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT IN TERMS OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE NEEDED
DOWN IN OUR SOUTH COAST AREAS.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF YOU KNOW SAND
REPLENISHMENT ISSUES WE HAVE
REVETMENT ISSUES SO YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR YOUR FOCUS
ON THAT ISSUE GO FORWARD BECAUSE
THAT CERTAINLY PART OF THE WHOLE --
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WHAT IT'S DOING --
SPECIFICALLY TO VARIOUS REGIONS
FIRST.
TOTALLY AGREE WE NEED A A
PORTION --
FUNDING --
ACROSS THE STATE --
AND THERE HAS BEEN I THINK A
VALID CRITICISM IN THE PAST
ACROSS PROGRAMS --
THAT --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MOST
POPULOUS REGION THE STATE
DOESN'T GET AT INAPPROPRIATE --
SHARE RESOURCE AND I KNOW SOME
ENTITIES INCLUDING THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL HAVE REALLY DONE
A DEEP DIVE IN UNDERSTANDING --
HOW WE CAN BE SURE THE FAIR
APPORTIONMENT SO YES ABSOLUTELY
RESOURCE AGENCY ARE REALLY
ALLOCATE A LOT OF BOND FUNDING
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON THAT?
AND THEN ON SEA LEVEL RISE.
ABSOLUTELY --
THIS IS A HUGE UNDER RECOGNIZE
CHALLENGE WITH COASTAL
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW AND A
TERRIBLY EXPENSIVE.
ONE THE STATE'S APPROACH IN THE
AGENCY'S APPROACH IS NUMBER ONE
TO REALLY --
HELP LOCAL COMMUNITIES
UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE RIGHT IS
TERRIBLY COMPLICATED AND WHAT
COMMUNITIES ONE UNDERSTAND IS
WHAT WILL THE IMPACT BE ON OUR
BEACHES ON OUR MARINO AS YOU
KNOW ON A COASTAL AREAS AND SO.
WE WORK TO REALLY TAKE WHAT IS
COMPLICATED PLANETARY SCIENCE
AND DOWNSCALE IT SO LOOKS SO
LOCAL LEADERS CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
DECISIONS ON THAT.
AND THEN BUILDING OFF THAT ARE --
REALLY LIKE A A GUIDE BOOK OR A
PLAY BOOK FOR DECISION MAKING --
ON ON SEA LEVEL RISE SO THE GOAL
IS TO PROVIDE A LOT OF TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE IN HOUSE.
BUT THEN WE NOW HAVE OBVIOUSLY
UP TO HELP COMMUNITIES BE ABLE
TO AFFORD THE CHANGES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE.
AND I'LL BE CAN'T CANDID I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU KNOW RESOURCES%
EXIST YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW IN
BETWEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS TO TO FULLY
ADDRESS.
ALL THE CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE
MADE BUT I'M CERTAINLY --
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
ADVANCE THE POLICIES IN THE
GUIDANCE BUT THEN ALSO FIND WAYS
TO DEVELOP RESOURCES TO HELP
COMMUNITIES LIKE YOURS THAT ARE.
WILL BE FACING THIS THIS ARE THE
THREAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE MORE
AND MORE IF.
AND I THINK IT HAPPENED WHAT
WILL WE RECEIVED A LOT OF
WARNINGS BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN IT
WAS HERE.
AND SEEING IT SIGNIFICANTLY THIS
YEAR OBVIOUSLY Là WITHOUT THE
RAINFALL WE'VE HAD.
A VERY QUICKLY SECOND QUESTION A
WE DID DISCUSS THE ISSUE OF
CLARK'S WHICH IS ANOTHER BIG.
ARM.
CONCERNED AREA LOG IN MY
COMMUNITY AND IN PARTICULAR I'LL
AGAIN OB MORE THIS NOR SAN DIEGO
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WANT TO PARTNER.
WITH STATE PARKS ON THE BEACH --
THE STATE PARKS ALONG THE
BEACHES AND THERE'S NOT BEEN.
LET'S SAY ON A GOOD COOPERATIVE
BY ENGAGEMENT AND I KNOW YOU OF
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND ARE.
COMMITTED TO YOU KNOW MAKING
I'LL BRING YOU MORE THE LOCALS
ARE ON BOARD AND BEYOND NOT
HELPING WITHOUT SO.
JUST ON THE RECORD IF YOU CHAIR
YOU OUT ON THAT BE DID --
TO THE SENATE WE HAVEN'T SOLVED
IT YEAH WAS FOUR YEARS AGO SO
YEAH.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'M REALLY
EXCITED AND ENERGIZED TO HELP
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE UR STATE
PARKS THE TALK ABOUT REALLY
CONNECTING PEOPLE --
AND ARE OUTDOORS STATE PARKS ARE
REALLY THE POINT OF THE SPEAR AT
THAT AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY YOU KNOW SEE
BENEFIT.
PARKS STATE PARKS I'M
PARTICULARLY IN YOUR DISTRICT
GIVEN ALL YOUR STATE BEACHES I
MEAN HUGE COMMUNITY ASSET.
I THINK THE PARKS DEPARTMENT OUR
STATE PARKS HAS HAS BUT ALSO
CONTINUES TO NEED TO TAKE THE
APPROACH THAT EACH PARK.
NEEDS TO BE MANAGED OBVIOUSLY TO
A STANDARD BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING
THE LOCAL CHARACTER OF THOSE
PARKS.
I'M IN THE COMMUNITY GROUPS THAT
ARE SOMETIMES EITHER FORMAL
PARTNERS OR INFORMAL PARTNERS AS
WELL AS THE CONCESSIONAIRES AND
THE VENDORS --
WHO ARE ACTUALLY PART OF THE
CULTURAL FABRIC OF THOSE PARKS
IT'S A PART OF A CHALLENGE WITH
THE STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT IS?
REALLY WORKING TO MODERNIZE ITS
SYSTEMS TO ENSURE A STRONG
FISCAL OVERSIGHT --
OF ALL OF IT PARKS SO HOW DO WE
MODERNIZE THOSE CONTRACTS --
BUT BRING BUT BUT SENSITIVE TO
YOU KNOW THOSE UNIQUE
CONCESSIONAIRES SO YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT AND I THINK IT'S WORK
WHERE THE KIND OF THE ROLLING UP
SLEEVES NATURE OF THE JOB COMES
THEN WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW MY TEAM AT THE
RESOURCES AGENCY WANTS TO HELP.
YOU ALL I PROBLEMS OFF AS YOU
THANK YOU I CONSTITUENTS HERE
CERTAINLY I YOU BàN OUT THERE
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT THAT ARE
VERY EXCITED.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
WELCOME SECRETARY CROWFOOT --
HAS A NICE RING TO IT IN A ONE
WELCOME YOUR FAMILY AS WELL AND
FRIENDS AND THANK THEM FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND SHARING YOU WITH.
THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
I ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY AND WE COVERED.
A LOT OF GROUND IN YOU'VE
MENTIONED SOME OF IT TODAY --
THE BIG PICTURE INCREASED COSTS
FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION MORE
INVESTMENT.
IN PREVENTION AND HARDENING
COMMUNITIES --
FROM A PUBLIC SAFETY PROTECTIVE
POINT OF VIEW.
IS YOUR AGENCY IN THE DEPARTMENT
YOU'LL DIRECT ADEQUATELY
RESOURCE FOR THE GREATER DEMANDS
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS BRINGING
TO OUR STATE AND OUR PLANET.
WELL I WILL TELL YOU --
AND THANK YOU THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR FOR ACTUALLY
THROUGH SB NINE A ONE YOU KNOW
ALLOCATING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR OR OR
PROPOSING TO ALLOCATE TO A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR FIVE
YEARS.
THAT REPRESENTS SKILLED OF
RESOURCES THAT'S GOING TO ALLOW
CAL FIRE TO DO THE FORCE WORK
AROUND THESE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES --
BUT DIRECTLY I THINK IT'S AN
OPEN QUESTION ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GONNA RESOURCES BROADER WILD
FIRE SAFETY IN FORCE MANAGEMENT --
CHALLENGE ARE WE HAVE --
WILDLANDS IN THE STATE ABOUT A
THIRD OF IT'S FORESTED IN
OAKLAND AT CETERA.
AND A LOT OF THAT --
I WOULD ARGUE NEEDS TO BE
MANAGED AND THAT'S OF A SCALE --
THAT FRANKLY DWARFS THE GENERAL
FUND ABILITY.
AND SO THEN THE QUESTION IS.
HOW DO YOU DEVELOP?
INCENTIVES I TO GET LOCAL
COMMUNITIES I AND OTHER PARTNERS
ON THE LAND TO ACTUALLY MANAGE
THE LAND.
I. IN SO BIO ENERGY FOR EXAMPLE
IS ONE I POTENTIAL SOLUTION
THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED I THINK
IT'S A BROAD POLICY DIALOGUE
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE IN COMING
YEARS.
BUT I THINK THAT AND I KNOW THAT
THANK THINKS THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR WE HAVE RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW THAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT THESE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU IN.
THAT'S KIND OF THE CRISIS FRONT
MAN THERE'S OUR ONGOING.
MAINTENANCE AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR PARKS ESPECIALLY
BUT OTHER.
ON RESOURCES UNDER YOUR
OVERSIGHT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND SEE HOW WE
CAN.
MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT.
ON THE LOSING END OF A TREADMILL
NOT INVESTING ENOUGH IN OUR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TO WHERE
THE COSTS CONTINUE TO RISE THE
THOUGHT SON.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE CHALLENGES
WELL I I THINK THE KNOWLEDGE
KNOWLEDGE THEM AS A CHALLENGE --
I MENTIONED OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND FUNDING THAT VOTERS HAVE
APPROVED I AND THAT FUNDING IS
REALLY VALUABLE.
I ENDED HAS GENERALLY BEEN FOR A
ONE TIME CAPITAL.
INVESTMENTS WHICH ARE TYPICALLY
WHAT GEO BONDS OR SPEND TIME.
IN SO ONE AREA THAT I'M FOCUSED
ON IS REALLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
ARE THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
OPERATE AND MAINTAIN.
OUR ASSETS WHETHER IT'S A PARK
OR IT'S A FOREST LAND OR YOU
KNOW IT'S A WILDLIFE PRESERVE --
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS
SPEND A LOT OF RESOURCES ON
UPGRADING ASSET OR OR DEVELOPING
AN ASSET AND THE NOT MAINTAINING
IT.
SO THAT'S AN AREA OF FOCUS IN
COMING MONTHS AND YEARS THANK
YOU AND THEN JUST A FINAL
QUESTION IF I MIGHT YOU
MENTIONED.
FIRE FLOOD IN C. RISE AS CRISES
FACING OUR STATE --
I KNOW YOU'VE ALSO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS OF CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND CLOSE TO A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
FLEA MAYBE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW
WE PRIORITIZE THIS SEASON WHAT
ROLE YEAH OR AGENCY MY EARLY
JUST FOLLOWING THE GOVERNOR'S --
YOU KNOW LEAD ON THIS.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CRISIS IN OUR
MIDST -- YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S LAST DIRECTLY
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
MORE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
NATURALLY OCCURRING --
YOU KNOW POLLUTION AND SOME YOU
KNOW CONTAMINATION OVER TIME BUT
I THINK MOST ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S AN
IT'S AN ISSUE WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH.
I AND THE GOVERNOR SAID ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS HE'S HOPING.
I THINK --
REASONABLE MINDS HAVE DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION AROUND HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS IT.
I AND WOULD CERTAINLY --
DEFERRED TO THE POLICY MAKERS
EXACTLY HOW THAT GETS DONE --
BUT I JUST KNOW YOU KNOW GIVING
VOICE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
INTENSITY ON THIS WE'RE HOPING
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY --
BE PART OF A SOLUTION THAT CAN
ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW BEGINNING.
THE END OF THE YEAR --
THERE'S ACTUALLY A PATHWAY TO
ENSURING THOSE FOLKS THAT LIVE
IN HOMES WITH TOXIC WATER I'M
ACTUALLY WILL GET RELIEF.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
ON GOING WORK ON THAT.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN YOUR AGENT SENIOR DEPARTMENTS.
AND I WOULD MAKE A MOTION BUT I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE ALREADY
RESERVED THE SPACE TO DO THAT
SAW THE FOR BACK TO THE CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M I
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU GAVE ME
YESTERDAY TO TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THESE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES YOU ARE.
YOU WILL BE OVERSEE IN AN AGENCY
THAT HAS SO MANY DIRECT.
IMPACTS ON SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CRITICAL ISSUES
THAT WE COULD HAVE SPENTHOURS I
THINK GOING INTO DETAIL.
OF FOR THE RECORD JUST SO I CAN
DO THIS FOR NOT ONLY.
FOR PEOPLE I KNOW IN MY IN MY
COMMUNITIES BUT BUT OTHER
SENATORS ASSAULT AND SEE VERY
IMPORTANT.
I TO ANY NUMBER OF OUR
COLLEAGUES.
OVER THE COUNTY LINE FROM WHAT
MY COUNTY BUT WE GET A GOOD VIEW
OF IT FROM.
NEAR BORREGO SO --
THAT THEY HAD A WONDERFUL TIME
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT THAT --
ISSUE CERTAINLY I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE --
ON PARKS AND HOW INVALUABLE
THOSE ARE FOR US AND THE
COMMITMENT WE NEED TO MAKE OUR
TO FIND WAYS TO SUPPORT AND
WHETHER IT'S STAFFING.
I OR ANY NUMBER OF THINGS AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FORESTRY
ISSUES I REALLY APPRECIATED WHEN
I ASK YOU.
WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
RIGHT NOW FACING YOU WE KNOW
THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGES BUT
THAT WAS TOP OF YOUR LIST AND
OBVIOUSLY?
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
AS IT RELATES TO OUR SITUATION
OF THE FIRES AND AND WHAT WE'RE
CONFRONTED WITH.
ON THAT OUR SCORE TO MY
COLLEAGUE AS A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIAN WHO COVERS.
ODD THE COASTAL AREA THE SEA
LEVEL RISE ISSUE THANK YOU FOR
TALKING ABOUT ALL OF THESE
ISSUES WE COULD HAVE SPENT HOURS.
I AND WITH THAT I WANT TO LIVE
AND I TO MY THANKS OF FOR THE
STAFF THAT YOU HAVE WHO ARE
INCREDIBLY RESPONSIBLE.
RESPONSIBLE AND RESPONSIVE TO
OUR CALLS YOU KNOW THAT
OBVIOUSLY --
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOU
CAN'T DO WHAT YOU DO.
WITHOUT ARE THE FOLKS WHO HAD UP
ALL OF THOSE BOARDS.
AND AGENCIES AND WHO CALL US
FIND TO OUR COMMUNITY CONCERNS
SO I DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I ASK ALL OF THEM AND
MY COLLEAGUES DID A REALLY GOOD
JOB I JUST WANTED TO LEND MY EYE
THANKS TO MY CONGRATULATIONS.
I AS WE START TO BRING UP FOLKS
WHO WILL.
SPEAK ARE IN SUPPORT ARE TO
BEGIN WITH SO WITH THAT LET ME
ASK THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF MISTER.
ARE CROWFOOT ARM CAN GET IN LINE
HERE AND I KNEW THAT THE WHOLE
ROOM WOULD STAND UP THAT'S A
GOOD THING --
BUT I AM GOING TO ASK YOU HAVE
IN THAT YOU OBVIOUSLY HEARD
COMMENTS FROM EVERYONE OF A
POSITIVE NATURE.
TELL ME YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS IF YOU WOULD I'LL LET
YOU BEGIN RIGHT --
THANK YOU CENTER AT CONCEIVE
CREWS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY --
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY PLEASED
TO BE HERE --
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
OF SECRETARY CROWFOOT --
I SOME OF MY TALKING POINTS THAT
ARE VERY.
MUCH IN LINE WITH WITH -
THE SECRETARY MENTIONED TERMS OF
HIS WORK STYLE AND BEING VERY
ACCESSIBLE INTERACT --
HIS WILLINGNESS TO REALLY ROLL
UP HIS SLEEVES AND WORK ON
ISSUES HE ALSO UNDERSTANDS.
ISSUES VERY WELL FROM I THINK
THAT REALLY ALLOWS HIM TO BRING
FOLKS TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH
THE INNOVATIVE AND CREATIVE
IDEAS TO SOLVING.
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX WATER
PROBLEMS INCLUDING ISSUES LIKE
THE SALTON SEA SO WE VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM
AND AND SUPPORTED HIS
CONFIRMATION.
OR SO I GET US ON BEHALF AT THE
HOME ON A RANCH IN SUPPORT OF
THE NOMINATION LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I TERRY MCHALE WITH ERIN READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING PEG
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
AND CAL FIRE LOCAL --
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE WE AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID
GOOD ABOUT HIM I THINK WAY IT'S
GOING TO BE BRILLIANT THE ONLY
THING WE WORRY ABOUT IS THAT.
HE'S RUINING THE BEST YEARS OF
HIS LIFE WE THINK YOU SHOULD LET
IT GROW A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
DANIEL GLASSER HIDE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES AND ALSO PUBLICLY
AND ELECTRIC UTILITIES THERE ARE.
A WHOLE HOST OF ISSUES MANY OF
THAT WERE BROUGHT OF TODAY
AFFECTING OUR MEMBERS AND ALSO
THE STATE AS A WHOLE AND WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH WITH MISTER CROW FED ON ON
THOSE ISSUES IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER WITH A
PRAYER MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF TWO
OF OUR CLIENTS CHARGE POINT AND
REPUBLIC SERVICES.
FIRST WE WANT TO COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR FOR MAKING THE RIGHT
CHOICE --
FOR THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES --
WE ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONFIRM HIS
APPOINTMENT I IN ONE OF MR
CRAWFORD'S PRIOR LIVES I'M AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF.
HE EGULARLY MET WITH CHARGE
POINT EXECUTIVES ON A. B.
INFRASTRUCTURE MATTERS THAT WERE
THEN PENDING BEFORE THE P. UC.
HE IS LET EFFORTS ON EVEY PERMIT
THOSE ARE NOW BEING UPDATED AND
AND IMPLEMENTED BY GOBIZ --
AND THROUGHOUT THAT HE HAS A
DEMONSTRATED THAT HE IS A
DEDICATED --
IN HIS --
SUPPORT FOR CLIMATE ACTION.
ON REGARDS TO REPUBLIC SERVICES --
THEIR EXPERIENCE WITH SECRETARY
CROWFOOT HAS --
FOUND THAT HE IS ALWAYS PREPARED
HE'S ACCESSIBLE AND REASONABLE
AND WHILE MY CLIENT MISTER
CRAWFORD HAVE NOT ALWAYS AGREED --
IT THEY WITH OF ALWAYS BEEN
REASONABLE AND AND THEIR
INTERACTION AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
YOUR CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TEM AND
MEMBERS I'M VICTORIA ROME WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND WE'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH MISTER
CROW FOOT AND MANY OF HIS
PREVIOUS LEADERSHIP ROLES.
AND I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT I
THINK THE EMPHASIS ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND DROUGHT
RESILIENCE IS IMPORTANT AND
UNFORTUNATELY NECESSARY GIVEN
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS AFFECTING
US ALL NOW THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIST.
REPRESENT THREE THOUSAND
SCIENTISTS AND STATE SERVICE
MANY OF WHOM WORK AT RESOURCES
AGENCY AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT IN
CONFIRMATION OF MISTER CRAWFORD
THANK YOU.
YOU.
RICH GORDON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION --
HERE TO SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION
OF MISTER CRAWFORD AND ALSO
PLEDGED THAT AS THE THE INDUSTRY
IS PREPARED TO WORK WITH YOU.
ON OF FORCED HEALTH AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE A THANK YOU.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT
UPON CALIFORNIA WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT OF HIS NOMINATION AND
CONFIRMATION HE'S BEEN A
THOUGHTFUL PARTNER AND NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES ESPECIALLY THE
SOLVENCY.
WHERE -- I
THINK ON DAY --
ONE HE HIT THE GROUND RUNNING
ND MAY MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS A
PRIORITY FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE FIND A
SOLTION NECESSARY. TO WIN
IMPENDING PROBLEM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MARTIN ST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HERE AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND THE
CONFIRMATION OF MISTER CRAWFORD
I JUST.
KNOW THAT HE HAS SHOWN
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP ARE
PARTICULARLY IN OUR PERSPECTIVE
WHEN HE LED THE GOVERNOR'S TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE.
ANYONE THAT CAN GET THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE A BUNCH OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
INTERESTS TO ALL TALK REGULARLY
AND COLLABORATIVELY SHOWS GREAT
LEADERSHIP.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM DELFINO WITH
A DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH --
SECRETARY CROWFOOT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS -- I
WAS ACTUALLY JUST AT THE SALTON
SEA YESTERDAY AND I ACTUALLY GOT
THE OPPORTUNITY OF VIEWING IT.
THOSE GOING THERE AND BACK FROM
pBORREGO WHICH BY THE WAY IT'S
REALLY BEAUTIFUL RIGHT NOW WELL
THE FLOWERS RE BLOOMING --
AND SO I JUST HE WAITED THIS
FROM OTHERS HE'S COMMITTED HE'S
CREATIVE HE'S COLLABORATIVE
THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT SKILLS
WITH DEALING WITH THE VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUES THAT FACE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT
TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM ON A VARIETY OF
ISSUES WATER FOREST'S SOLVENCY
AND WASN'T REALLY MENTIONED MUCH
TODAY BUT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE NEED --
TO WORK ON GETTING THEIR HOUSE
IN ORDER THROUGH THE MISSION
BEST MISSION BASED BUDGETING
EXERCISE WHICH I THINK WILL BE
BENEFITTED PARKS GREATLY AND I
THINK WILL BENEFIT.
THE OF W. THANK YOU WAIT.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACY HEATING
WITH ROCK COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA HERE ON BEHALF OF
FOUR THIRTY SIX RURAL COUNTIES.
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION TODAY
SECRETARY CROWFOOT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH HIM FOR A NUMBER OF
MONTHS SINCE HIS SEVERAL WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN ON THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE.
WHAT ARE BOARD APPRECIATES ABOUT%
HIM MOST IS THAT HE IS A PERSON
OF ACTION WHEN HE STARTED ON THE
TASK FORCE HE GOT IN THERE AND
GOT ON THE GROUND WITH US?
WE WENT AND WE TOWARD THE FOREST
TOGETHER AND WE LOOKED AT BUT
KILLS HE'S AND WE WALKED AROUND
YOU TEND TO BOND WHEN YOU DO
THAT -- BUT
HE WENT OUT WITH OUR MEMBERS
VISITED A NUMBER OF OUR COUNTIES
AND AND HE GETS TO WORK AND HE
SAW THE URGENCY IN IT AND REALLY
MADE SURE THAT THAT TASK FORCE
GOT UP AND RUNNING AND REALLY
GOT WORK DONE IN THAT WE ALL
TALKED AND AND WORKED.
AND GOT THINGS ACCOMPLISHED AND
WE SEE NOTHING CHANGING ABOUT
THAT AND IN THIS ROLE GOING
FORWARD AND WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM.
AND WE SUPPORT HIM TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DAVID GUY WITH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER JOINT DAY BY MY
COLUMN ADAM ROBIN --
SUPPORTERS SECRETARY CROWFOOT
CONFIRMATION --
I THINK BOTTOM LINE HE'S GOT THE
IMAGINATION HE'S GOT THE PASSION
HE'S GOT THE RESOLVE I THINK TO
A RELEASE SOURCES CHALLENGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYBODY BETTER THAT I
CAN THINK OF TO BE IN THAT
POSITION SO.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MEMBER THEM MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DANIEL KIM I'M ONE OF THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE WASN'T SOLAR
PARK WHICH IS BEING DEVELOPED BY
THE GOALS THEY CLEAN ENERGY
ENERGY V. PARTNERSHIP WITH CIM.
WE ARE THE LARGEST RENEWABLE
ENERGY PROJECT IN THE UNITED
STATES LOCATING KINGS COUNTY
ENTIRELY ON DRAINAGE.
IMPAIRED FARMLAND AND ONE OF THE
AREAS IN WHICH MR CROWFOOT.
IS GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT --
LEADER IN LOOKING AT HOW WE DEAL
WITH THE THE RETIREMENT OF THESE
LANDS UNDER THE CIGNA --
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A WORKING WITH HIM.
SEEING HOW WE CAN REALLY HELP
CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITIES --
AS WE YOU KNOW CONVERT THESE
LANDS ENTIRE PURPOSE OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRO TEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WENDY RUETER WHICH
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES ARE
AQUA.
WE'VE HAD SUCH A PRODUCTIVE
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP IN
YOUR IN THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
AND MORE RECENTLY WITH THE WATER
FOUNDATION SO WE JUST SO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING NOT WORK --
INTO THE FUTURE HEARING
CONGRADULATIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRETEND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JAY ZIEGLER THAT
DIRECTOR --
POLICY AN EXTERNAL AFFAIRS AT
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
DELIGHTED TO HAVE HAD A NUMEROUS
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK WITH
SECRETARY CROWFOOT IN PRIOR
ROLES -- AND
JUST CANDIDLY SEE NO BETTER
CANDIDATE TO LEAD AND INTEGRATE
THE WORK --
THIS --
MULTI DISCIPLINARY --
SOMETIMES VIEWED AS DIVIDED
MISSION DEPARTMENT AND REALLY
HELP --
INTEGRATE THAT DEPARTMENT FOR
RESPONSE OF STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS EVERYTHING FROM
AFFORDABLE DRINKINGWATERTHE
HOW WE ADDRESS --
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CONNECTIVITY
ACROSS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LANDS
AND REALLY LOOK FORWARD. TO HIS
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING THE
DEPARTMENT TOGETHER NOMINATION
THANK YOU.
AND IBM MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER APPEARING HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE OFFICERS FOUNDATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME
MANAGERS AND SUPERVISORS
ASSOCIATION AND I WAS VERY
PLEASED YESTERDAY TO WITNESS
SECRETARY COVERT SWEARING IN SAN
DIEGO'S OWN SAMANTHA MURRAY. TO
THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION YESTERDAY HE'S GREAT
AT SWEARING IN WHICH IS A KEY
ROLE FOR THE SECRETARY --
ALSO GRATEFUL THAT HE'S ALREADY
BEEN ACCESSIBLE AND SUPPORTIVE
OF EFFORTS TO RESOLVE
COMPENSATION IN EQUITY ISSUES
FOR CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE
OFFICERS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND WHO ENFORCE RESOURCE
PROTECTIVE LAWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SEES FIT TO AN ACT
OFTEN.
THEY DO IT IN THE FACE OF
TREMENDOUS CREST SO WHERE DO YOU
TO CONFIRM WAY TO SECRETARY WE
CONGRATULATE YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOW TO PROTECT THE MEMBERS JOE
DIVIDE WITH PLATINUM VISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FISH
AND GAME WARDENS ASSOCIATION
JUST ONE ECHO EVERYTHING THAT
MISS FEARING SAID.
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE AND THE DEPARTMENT THANKS
MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM MARK
FRIENDS TO MAKE ON BEHALF THE
CINEMA COUNTY WATER AGENCY OR
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT ENERGY
THE CONFIRMATION OF SECRETARY
CROWFOOT.
OP REALLY PLEASED TO HEAR HIS
FOCUSES COMMENTS AROUND CLIMATE
RESILIENCY.
OUT IN CINEMA COUNTY WE
CERTAINLY EXPERIENCE MANY OF THE
EFFECTS ALREADY OF OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE THE FIRES THE
DROUGHT NOW FLOODS IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MISTER CRAWFORD --
ON THOSE ISSUES AS WE GO FORWARD
THANK YOU.
MADAM FOR TâM AND MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS OUR ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA PACIFIC INDUSTRIES AND
GREEN DIAMOND.
RESOURCES COMPANY A VERY PLEASED --
TO SUPPORT THAT MISTER
CRAWFORD'S NOMINATION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M CHAIR MEMBERS TWENTY
MANALO OF CALIFORNIA STRATEGIES
I WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA FORCE
CARBON COALITION.
FILL THE TEN GROUPS LIKE THE
YUROK TRIBE HERE PACIFIC
INDUSTRIES CONSERVATION FUND A
NUMBER OF OTHERS --
THAT SUIT EACH OTHER ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS AGO IN OUR WORKING
TOGETHER COOPERATIVELY.
IN A WAY THAT WE WOULDN'T
FORCING ABOUT A DECADE AGO --
A NUMBER OF US JUST CAME FROM
TODAY IS A WILDLIFE --
MEETING THAT'S HAPPENING AND SO
THERE WAS CAL FIRE --
YES A NUMBER OF MEMBERS THAT
WERE UP THERE THAT ALL TALKED
ABOUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WAS TO
HAVE PEOPLE WORK TOGETHER.
MOVING FORWARD TO TACKLE THE
FIRED CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE I
CAN THINK OF NOBODY BETTER THAN
WAIT CROWFOOT WHO OVER THE
TWENTY YEARS THAT I KNOW HAND.
HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
BRINGING PARTIES I WOULD NEVER
THOUGHT COME TOGETHER SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
WITH A SECRETARY.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR WALKER RIGHT WITH
ANGIE WHICH IS THE LARGEST --
GLOBAL INDEPENDENT POWER
PRODUCER AT KNOWN WITH A
PROFESSIONALLY FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS NOW AS WELL AS PERSONALLY
I CAN'T.
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE THOUGHTS
OF EVERYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM --
WAIT HAS A STRONG HISTORY OF
COLLABORATION AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE AND SOLAR WATER AND
FIRE AND WE REALLY REALLY LOOK
FOR TWO IS LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DAVE CANNELLA FORMER LIFE I USED
TO WORK WITH MISTER CRAWFORD AND
I THINK HE HAS SOME REALLY
UNIQUE ABILITIES SO THIS IS A
GREAT CHOICE.
FOREMOST AMONG WHICH I THINK
THEY'RE FEW PEOPLE I CAN SAY OR
ABLE TO NAVIGATE AND STRATEGIZE
THROUGH DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
IN CRISIS SITUATIONS.
AND THE OTHER THING IS IS A BILL
ABILITY TO LISTEN TO OTHERS AND
FIND OUTCOMES THAT MOST PEOPLE
WOULD BE ABLE TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NUMBER TEN MEMBERS OF THE SENATE --
MY KNEES BRANDING OR SEE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TROUT
RECOVERY ASSOCIATIONAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS THE ALL
STAR ONE ECHO THE SUPPORT --
FOR SECRETARY PROFIT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NO ONE ELSE ARE WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SENATORS BATES.
BATES HI MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROUGH AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
IT IS UNANIMOUS CONGRADULATIONS.
OF WHILE ANA.
WE ARE HERE I WANT TO ASK A MAN
AND SECRETARY --
TO LIVE THE CALL ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ITEMS TWO THROUGH SEVEN SENATORS
BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS
FIVE ZERO AND NOW WE ARE GOING
TO GO INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION
THANK YOU